what's going on guys this is Rob and I
want to make a video real quick kind of
letting you guys know what's going on I
have started a patreon it's not really a
requirement I mean if you guys are
welcome to go check it out it's you know
patreon.com forward slash comics explain
you'll find a link down in the
description in truth this is really a
move that's made because of the stuff
that YouTube's taken there's a lot of
you guys probably know by now YouTube
announced that they're basically telling
all the content creators below 1,000
subscribers in less than 4,000 views you
know lifetime lifetime I'm sorry
4,000 lifetime watched hours that um
that they can't monetize on YouTube
anymore
of course my channel is bigger than that
but in truth in my mind I feel like the
smaller content creators the ones that
are around a thousand subs you know
either a little bit above it or maybe a
little bit below it those are those
that's the lifeblood of YouTube because
every single youtuber out there whether
it's PewDiePie markiplier jacksepticeye
philip defranco whatever the case may be
there was a time where they all had no
subscribers and the only sub they had
was like their best friend there was a
time when that was the case you know
that time may have been 10 years ago it
may have been five years ago it may have
been four years ago but there was a time
when they had no no subscribers
whatsoever and to you know for you to
become along and basically tell the
smaller content creators you're the
least of our concerns we're not really
too worried about you that's a problem
that's the major issue because that
means that a huge portion of the youtube
user base could effectively go away not
only that the way that YouTube works
YouTube has a history and I'm pretty
sure this has been proven time and time
again YouTube suppresses videos that
aren't monetized and I'm part of the
creator the partner program and so what
that means is that if you have less than
a thousand subscribers and you have less
than 4 or 4,000 hours viewed on your
YouTube channel and you upload a video
and you're not you're not gonna be
allowed into the part of program
YouTube's not gonna promote that for you
they're not gonna put it in the
suggested videos which means you only
hope you have of your channel growing is
someone giving you a shout-out or
something along those lines and that's a
problem because what it means is now
it's really kind of like closing the
door on the ability for content creators
you know to grow their brands I mean I
tell people all the time I got lucky I
didn't I don't know how you know I
didn't know how YouTube works to a
degree I'm still trying to figure it out
but for the first three years of my
channel I was flying by the seat of my
pants that every content creator is
that's part of the YouTube game is
figuring out how it works trying to find
that balance but
what you're hardcore fans want and what
the you know vocal I'm sorry with a
silent majority want trying to find that
middle ground and do it in a way that
makes your channel grow but I think
YouTube kind of penalizing these small
channels is ridiculous because they're
the lifeblood of the platform they're
what makes it grow you know the hope for
a bigger channel the hope for being able
to have a self-sustaining job the hope
for turning their their platform you
know their YouTube channel into a career
is what I imagine drives a lot of these
content creators and then for YouTube to
basically shut the door in their face
and say sorry about your luck hopefully
you break a thousand subs and you know
four thousand hours but if you don't
that's your problem it's gonna drive
people to other places and that's why
I'm launching this patreon because
taking steps like this means YouTube's
cutting down on its on its it's time for
I mean I did an open letter to YouTube
saying look here's what I think is gonna
happen and long and short of that open
letter if you guys never saw the video
is that I think YouTube's cutting itself
off at the knees I think YouTube's grown
arrogant I think YouTube's grown
complacent I think YouTube sitting
around and they're like we have Google
money who cares like we can do whatever
we want to and I really kind of into
that letter and saying myspace and Vine
had the same attitude until they stopped
until you know myspace lost a majority
of its of its user base and never
recovered and vine shut down so I mean
you know I think that in the direction
that YouTube's going in there slowly and
steadily killing their platform do I
think YouTube will go away forever
no YouTube will always be around but I
think Facebook watch I think Amazon
launching a video sharing platform I
think patreon you know I could see
patreon integrating itself with twitch I
could see you know Amazon coming along
and having the twitch live streaming
platform and the trich via twitch video
on-demand platform is two completely
separate sites and then basically
creating their own version of YouTube
there's there's ample room for
competitors in this market and things
like this only drive those those
competitors into you know really into a
place where fans see them as a viable
option where maybe they didn't see them
before and so I don't know but in light
of all this you know I kind of feel like
it's affected a launch of patreon
because I've got employees to pay you
know I've got I've got employees of
families that I've got employees that
are trying to you know either put
themselves through college or save up
for retirement you know I'm saving up
for each time I do the same thing I've
got a house you know I mean there's all
these things that go on with the with
regards to the the YouTube money that I
generate you know that in all honesty
it's not just me and so
that's a result I don't want to see that
go away I want to continue making
content for you guys I'm gonna continue
talking about coming books for you guys
I'd love talking about that kind of
stuff so you know I'm it's not like I've
lost everything YouTube hasn't D
monetize my channel in its entirety for
the most part I'm fine this was really
more of a precautionary measure it's
really just kind of a back-up plan with
regards to the fact that maybe things
would go south on YouTube but I have no
idea but anyway guys I just want to make
you all aware of what's going on
again that links down the description if
you want to check it out don't feel like
you have to what I'm probably going to
do in order to basically reward people
who are patrons because I want to make
sure that people have a reason you know
incentive if they if they feel inclined
what I'll probably do is do live streams
and just keep those contained at patreon
and then everything like you'll continue
to see the same programming you always
have and you'll make it level mutants
and character discussions and stories
and all I kind of good stuff
it's not going anywhere all that stuff
will still be publicly available I think
that what I might deal with with patreon
is I might host live streams and only
patrons can see and then do meetups that
only patrons can attend and then of
course do you meet ups with everybody
else you know that kind of a thing but I
want to make sure that if somebody
decides that they're gonna spend their
hard-earned money and they're gonna
contribute to me that they're damn well
gonna be rewarded for it I mean that's
that's you know that need that's what
needs to happen you know I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna tell you guys hey if
you're willing you know shell over your
cash and then what you get a return is
like maybe a video like that's that's
not very that's not very effective to me
I feel like people should be rewarded
for the kind of things they do but
anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
read this video to an end and I will
catch you all later peace